passons de l'inné et l'acquis la mode un
sondage ipsos révèle rico hit parade des
garçons de 12 à 24 ans ce sont david
bowie et christophe lambert qui sont les
mieux habillées un sondage qui révèle
par ailleurs que l'idée de mode
désormais fait son chemin dans les
esprits masculin alexandre rosada que
l'on aime ou pas la mode consacré
culture en notre temps n'est plus le
seul fait de la coquetterie ou de
l'élégance féminine
on s'en doutait mais voilà que vient le
confirmer ipsos avec un sondage effectué
auprès de jeunes garçons de 12 à 24 ans
l'idée de mode est donc définitivement
acceptée et que l'on soit comme ici avec
issey miyake ou autres jean paul
gaultier montana et tard l'asie 30% des
jeunes c'est énorme donne à la mode un
rôle prépondérant dans leurs choix
vestimentaires
alors que 86 % considèrent qu'être à la
mode c'est se sentir bien dans sa peau
sans oublier que c'est aussi une façon
d'être homme moderne s'il influence
vient surtout des copains c'est plutôt
le style et la forme qui retient
l'attention que la qualité et le confort
qui arrivent plus tard
enfin quand ils se définissent eux-mêmes
les jeunes et sting leur style pas du
tout pack très peu bcbg ou baba cool
presque pas branché mais plutôt sportif
voilà de quoi rassurer les parents